สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนเช่น
กันค่ะขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้อง
เรียน comprehensive  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษา
ไทยค่ะค่ะห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาตินะ
คะวันนี้เรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะครูชิวัน
นี้วันอังคารค่ะครูบีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 5
ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
มีนาคมปีพ.ศล่ะคะ
2567 ปีค.ศรอคะ
2024 ค่ะวันนี้เรามาเจอกันนะคะวันอังคาร
ที่ 5 มีนาคมค่ะนะคะแล้ววันนี้เรา 2 คน
เนี่ยแน่นอนเอ่อครูบีทานอาหารกลางวันหรือ
ยังคะออครูบีรู้สึกหิวมากเลยค่ะยังไม่ได้
ทานเลยค่ะครูชิตายถ้าเกิดครูชิคุยเรื่อง
ของกินเนี่ยครูบีอาจจะเริ่มหิวมากขึ้นใช่
ค่ะคือูชิสังเกตได้เลยเวลาที่เรายังไม่
ได้ทานข้าวยังไม่ได้กินอาหารเช้าแล้วมีคน
พูดถึงอาหารเมนูอาหารหรือเรามีรูปมาให้
เราดูใช่มั้ยอืมมีคนเอารูปมาแล้วให้เราดู
หรือว่าเรามีโทรศัพท์เปิดเปิด Facebook
ขึ้นไปโอ้โหส้มตำไก่ทอดอย่างเงี้ยค่ะขน
น้ำลายจะไหลใช่เช็ดน้ำลายอืเห็นรูปเนี่ย
ก็จะรู้สึกหิวค่ะทำไมคะครูชิวันนี้ครูชิ
จะมาคุยเรื่องเกี่ยวกับอาหารเหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
แต่มันเป็นของกินเล่นอืเรามีของกินเล่น
เยอะนะคนไทยของกินเล่นๆกินไม่จริงจังแต่
อิ้มิอือฮึเเดี๋ยวนะของกินเล่นของคนไทย
เนี่ยชาวต่างชาติกินอาจจะกินสำหรับเป็น
อาหารแล้วอิ่มไปเลยก็ได้ใช่แต่เราบอกมัน
ไม่ใช่ข้าวไงอะไรที่ไม่ใช่ข้าวเนี่ยคนไทย
คิดโอ๊ยมันเป็นของที่กินเล่นๆเป็นของว่าง
เป็นขนมอะไรแบบเนี้ยอเหมือนเค้กใช่มั้ย
ช็อกโกแลตอ่าเราก็เอามากินเล่นๆเวลาโอ
ว่างๆมีเวลาอีก 10 นาทีต้องสอนออนไลน์อ่ะ
กินเล่นๆ
อ่ากินขนมหรือว่ากินพวกอ่าพวกเลนะเป็นพวก
เฟรนช์ฟรายทอดอย่างเงี้ยก็ได้ค่ะอือุย
อย่างเฟรนช์ฟรายทอดเนี่ยเราก็เรียกมันทอด
ได้มยมันฝรั่งทอด
ออแต่เวลากล้วยทอดเนี่ยค่ะทำไมคะทำไมทำไม
เนี่ยกล้วย
แขกคูชิ
กล้วย
ทอดทำไมถึงเรียกกล้วยกล้วยแขกใช่ตอนเด็กๆ
สงสัยมากค่ะว่ามันก็คือกล้วยแล้วก็มาชุบ
กับแป้งหรืออะไรสักอย่างแล้วก็มีงาสีขาวๆ
เล็กๆแล้วก็เอาลงไปในน้ำมันทอดอ่ะทำไม
ทำไมเรียกกล้วยแขกคะเออเมื่อกี้ครูชิถาม
ครููบีใช่มยว่าเฟรนช์ฟรายเนี่ยเป็นมัน
ฝรั่งทอดเพราะฉะนั้นก็มีมันแล้วก็มาหั่นๆ
หๆเป็นชิ้นแล้วก็มีแป้งสีขาวแล้วก็คลุก
แป้งแล้วก็เอาลงไปทอดกับน้ำมันมันก็เลย
เป็นเฟรนช์ฟรายอือหือหรืออาจจะไม่ต้องผสม
แป้งก็ได้อ่าใช่ไม่ต้องชุบแป้งก็ได้เออ
เราก็เรียกมันฝรั่งทอดแต่พอเป็น
กล้วยแล้วก็เอาไปผสมน้ำตาลผสมงาแล้วก็ชุบ
แป้งลงไปทอดทำไมเรียกกล้วยแขก
เออคเนี้ยูชิตอนเด็กๆไงก็สงสัยไงก็ถามคุณ
พ่อไงค่ะทำไมไม่เรียกกล้วยทอดคะทำไมเรียก
กล้วยแขกคะเออคุณพ่อคูชิบอกว่าก็เมื่อ
ก่อนน่ะไม่มีคนไทยทอดไงอ้าจริงเหรอคะแกมา
โทษ
โอครูบีก็สงสัยนะทำไมเรียกกล้วยแขกแต่ไม่
รู้จะถามใคร
อืแต่พ่อูชิบอกว่าไม่มีคนไทยทอดเหรอคะูชิ
ที่พ่อูชิเนี่ยพูดก็อาจจะเป็นประสบการณ์
ที่เคยเห็นไงเค้าจะเห็นคนมุสลิมอ่ะที่มี
ผ้าพวกแบบเนี้ยแล้วก็มาทำกล้วยกล้วยกล้วย
ทอดนะเค้าก็เลยจะเรียกว่ากล้วยแขกไงเพราะ
คนไทยจะมีกล้วยเอาไปย่างเเรียกกล้วยปิ้ง
ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็เอามาทับแบนๆแล้วก็จิ้มเอ่อ
น้ำกะทิน้ำตาลน่ะกินอ่ะอ่าอันนั้นเราบอก
ว่ากล้วยทับนะคะแต่มันมีกล้วยที่มาทำ
อาหารหลายๆอย่างทำขนมหลายๆอย่างเขาก็เลย
เรียกกล้วยท่อนี้ว่ากล้วยแขก
อืมีคนมุสลิมเท่านั้นที่จะมาทอดขายพ่อก็
เลยให้ให้ข้อสังเกตแบบนั้นออืไม่ใช่คนไทย
ที่มาทอดกล้วยขายเป็นแขกมาทอดกล้วยขาย
อย่างเงี้เหรอคะใช่ค่ะแต่ครูชี้นะ
ปัจจุบันเนี้ยเราจะเห็นคนไทยทั้งนั้นเลย
ค่ะที่มาทอดกล้วยขายเนี่ยอืกล้วยแขกเนี่ย
ค่ะเออก็ก็เลยอาจจะมีคนที่เรียกกล้วยแขก
น้อยลงนะอือาจจะมาเรียกกล้วยทอดมากขึ้น
ออเนาะเพราะว่าตอนครูชิครูวีเด็กๆนะพอเรา
โตโตขึ้นโตขึ้นเราก็เริ่มแบบเห็นเป็นคน
ไทยเที่ทอดกล้วยขายนะคะอ่าก็จะมีบางร้าน
เป็นร้านเล็กๆอยู่ข้างหน้าบิ๊กซีโลตัสน่ะ
ูบีก็เคยเห็นนะเขาก็จะเขียนว่ากล้วยทอด
อ่าแต่บางร้านก็จะเขียนว่ากล้วยแขก
อ่าเอมันก็จะมีป้ายเขียนนะคะเขียนภาษาไทย
นะ
อืก็ก็ก็สงสัยเนาะ
อืทีเนี้ยถ้าเกิดเราไปค้นหาความรู้นะต้อง
เป็นความรู้ที่มีผู้รู้อ่ะมาบอกเค้าก็บอก
นะว่ากล้วยแขกเนี่ยในไทยเนี่ยมีประวัติ
ความเป็นมายังไงก็ไม่รู้แน่ชัดไม่แน่ชัด
ก็คือแบบไม่มีใครชัวร์การันตีว่าอันเนี้ย
ต้องเป็นแบบนี้นะคะอือแต่เค้าก็บอกบอกว่า
กล้วยแขกเนี่ยก็น่าจะเป็นอาหารที่มาจาก
วัฒนธรรมการปรุงอาหารแบบคนชาวอินเดียซึ่ง
คนไทยจะเรียกคนอินเดียว่าแขกอืมอ้าเดี๋ยว
มีคำถามอีกนะครูชิทำไมเรียกคนอินเดียว่า
แขก
อ้อมีคือคำว่าแขกเนี่ยแปลว่าแบบมีที่มา
แตกต่างไม่เหมือนเราอ่ะ
อืถ้าเป็นทางบ้านครูบีนะครูชิตอนครูบี
เด็กๆเนี่ยอายุอ่า 7 ขวบ 8 ขวบนะบ้านครู
บีเเนี่ยอยู่ทางภาคอีสานออก็มีแขกไป
เยี่ยมนะครูชิเออคนที่เราไม่รู้จักถ้า
เกิดมาหาเราแล้วเราไม่รู้จักเราก็จะบอก
ว่าแม่มีแขกมาหาใช่มั้ยอืใช่แต่เมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยทางภาคอีสานจะมีแขก
มาเยอะมากเนี่ยแล้วไม่ใช่คนไทยไงกูชิอ๋อ
หน้าตาเนี่ยก็มีผิวสีค้ำมีหนวดมีหนวดแล้ว
ก็มีเข่าบางคนมีผ้าโพกหัว
ด้วยเออสวัสดีครับอืเอามุ้งมยครับเอามุ้ง
ม
ครับคนอีสานบอกแขกขายมุ้งนะเมื่อก่อนเยอะ
มากนะครูชิทางภาคอีสานก็บอกแม่แขกมาขาย
มุ้งแม่แขกมาขายของเ่มออมาที่บ้านอืเอ
โอเคงั้นดูที่มาของคำว่าแขกก่อนแขกที่ใน
ความหมายของครูบีนั้นก็คือคนที่เราไม่รู้
จักใช่แล้วก็มาที่บ้านออใช่เราก็จะบอกว่า
เอ่อแล้วก็จะมีห้องนึงใช่มั้ยสำหรับต้อน
รับเราก็เรียกว่าห้องรับแขกใช่เพราะว่า
บางทีบ้านคนไทยใช่มั้ยคะอ่ามีบ้าน 1 หลัง
ก็จะมีห้องสำหรับต้อนรับแขกสมมุติครูชิมา
ที่บ้านครูบีก็จะมีห้องรับแขกนะเราไม่ให้
ไปอยู่บนห้องนอนนะก็จะมีห้องสำหรับอ่าแขก
มาเนาะอาจจะเป็นคนที่เรารู้จักหรือไม่รู้
จักอาจจะมาเจอใครไม่มาเจอคุณพ่อคุณแม่
อย่างงี้เนาะเราก็จะบอกแม่ใครไม่
รู้มีแขกมาหาไม่รู้จักแขกคนเนี้ยไม่รู้
จักบอกอยากคุยกับคุณแม่
ออนะทีเนี้ยในกลุ่มที่เราเรียกแขกจริงๆ
เนี่ยเขาบอกว่ามีอยู่ 3 กลุ่มค่ะครูบีอ่า
มีกลุ่มอะไรบ้างคะครูชิแขกแรกเนี่ยก็หมาย
ถึงแขกคนอินเดียค่ะมาจากประเทศอินเดียอ่า
คนไทยก็เรียกแขกเหรอคะซึ่งมากๆมาก็จะเป็น
กลุ่มแขกที่เป็นนับาะนนับถามนับถือศาสนา
ฮินดู
อืมีชิวะมีพรหมมีเอ่อพระนารายณ์เป็นแบบ
เป็นพระเจ้าอ่ะนะูชิเข้าใจแล้วค่ะพอูชิ
บอกว่านับถือศาสนาฮินดูมีพระศิวะมีพระแม่
มาลีเนี่ยกรุงเทพฯก็มีวัดที่ชื่อว่าวัด
แขกนะใช่เห็นมยอืครูบีอย่าเริ่มเข้าใจะ
วัดที่เป็นของคนฮินดูเราก็เรียกว่าวัดแขก
เออเพราะฉะนั้นมีอาหารของคนแบบมุสลิมเออ
มุสลิมก็จะเป็นแบบแขกอีกกลุ่มนึงนะเป็น
แขกมาลายูหรือมาเลเซียอินโดนีเซียอันนี้
จะเป็นแขกที่นับถือศาสนามุสลิมอือ่าอยู่
ทางใต้ของประเทศไทยค่ะแขกมาลายูหรือ
มุสลิมเนี่ยบางทีก็ขึ้นมาในพภาคกลางอนะคะ
คนมุสลิมก็จะมีอาหารของเค้าเหมือนกันใช่
มั้ยบางทีเราก็จะเรียกอย่างอย่างมีอาหาร
ประเภทอะไรเป็นสลัดแต่สลัดเค้าอหน้าตาไม่
เหมือนสลัดผักของคนไทยอ่ะเราก็จะเรียกอัน
นั้นว่าสลัดแขกอืมเออเนาะโอคำว่าแขกนี่มา
จากหลายความหมายมากนะคือเราคนไทยเรียกคน
อินเดียใช่มั้ยว่าแขกใช่อ่า
เรียกคนที่นับถือศาสนาฮินดูนะอ่าก็บอกว่า
อยู่ที่วัดเนี่ยก็เป็นวัดแขก
อ่าคนเรียกคนที่มาจากอินโดนีเซียมา
มาเลเซียหรือกลุ่มแขกมุสลิมเราก็เรียกว่า
แขกอันนี้เป็นแขกที่ 2 ออืนะกลุ่มแขกที่ 3
เนี่ยเป็นแขกเทศน์เป็นกลุ่มพวกพวกอาหรับ
เปอร์เซียอืนะกลุ่มพวกนี้ก็นับถือศาสนา
มุสลิมเหมือนกันแต่มาไกลแต่เขคจะมีสีผิว
เนี่ยแตกต่างจากแขกอินเดียไงแขกอินเดียจะ
ผิวสีสีดำสีแทนสีน้ำตาลเหมือนคนไทยอ่ะอ่า
ผิวจะเหมือนๆคนไทยแต่ถ้าเป็นเดนอสใช่มั้ย
คะเป็นพวกอาหรับเนี่ยเขาจะเป็นแขกขาวผิว
ขาวเราก็จะเรียกแขกพวกนี้ว่าแขกขาวเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยคำว่าแขกของคนไทยเนี่ยจะมี
อยู่ 3 กลุ่มอใช่มั้ยกลุ่มที่มาจาก
อินเดียนับถือฮินดูกลุ่มที่มาจากมาเลเซีย
มาลูอินโดนีเซียนับถือศาสนาเอ่ออิสลาม
เป็นกลุ่มแขกมุสลิมอิลามอืกลุ่มที่ 3
เป็นแขกอาหรับเปอร์เซียเราเรียกว่าแขกขาว
อืมนะคะหรือบางทีก็คือแขกนั่นแหละเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราก็มาดูตรง 3 กลุ่มเนี้ยว่า
แขก 1 แขก 2 แขก 3 เนี่ยไอ้กล้วยแขกเนี่ย
มาจากกลุ่มไหนนั่นน่ะสิก็กูชิบอกว่าตอน
ูชิเด็กๆก็มีคนเอากล้วยมาทอดแล้วก็เรียก
ว่ากล้วยแขกคุณพ่อูชิก็บอกว่าอ๋อเพราะว่า
แขกเป็นคนขายใช่มั้ยแล้วแขกกลุ่มไหนละ
กลุ่ม 1 กลุ่ม 2 หรือกลุ่ม 3 อืกลุ่ม 3
เนี่ยตัดออกไปเลย
เพราะว่าอาหารของคนอาหรับเปอร์เซียเนี่ย
ก็จะไม่มีแบบเป็นลักษณะแบบกล้วยทอดนะแต่
จะมีกลุ่มที่ที่ที่ทำแบบกล้วยทอดเนี่ยก็
คือแขกมาลายูนะคะก็เป็นกลุ่มมุสลิมนะนี่
หน้าตากล้วยทอดเค้าก็คล้ายๆกล้วยทอดของ
เรานะแต่เพียงแต่กล้วยเค้าไม่เหมือนกล้วย
ของ
เราเดี๋ยวนะดูกล้วยเค้าเนี่ยโอ้โหโหโเท่า
แขนใช่แล้วก็ไม่เหมือนกล้วยหอมไม่เหมือน
กล้วยน้ำว้าของเรานะคือคือรู้สึกว่ากล้วย
จะใหญ่กว่านะอ่าแต่ก็เป็นเมนูกล้วยทอด
เหมือนกันใช่มั้ยคะใช่เขาจะไปชุบแป้งแล้ว
ก็มาทอดกับกระทะที่มีน้ำมันเยอะๆอือันนี้
เป็นกล้วยแบบมาลูอืมนะคะอย่างถ้าเกิดคน
อินเดีย
คนอินเดียก็จะมีกล้วยทอดเหมือนกันแต่เขา
จะมีแป้งที่เป็นเหมือนกับผงกะหรี่อ่ะสี
เหลืองๆเฮ้ยขมิ้นไม่ใช่ผงกะหลีเป็นขมิ้น
อ๋อใส่ขมิ้นเหลืองๆ
ใช่เป็นชุกแป้งที่ใส่ขมิ้นเหลืองๆแล้วก็
เอาไปทอดคือเป็นแบบสไตล์ของอินเดียถูก
มั้ยคะอ่าใส่ขมิ้นเนาะเพราะคนอินเดียจะมี
เครื่องเทศน์เยอะเห็นมั้ยมันก็จะสีเหลือง
มากเลยเลยนะคะใช่แล้วก็ทอดทั้งลูกค่ะ
ออ 1 ลูกเอาชุบแป้งใช่ขมิ้นแล้วก็ทอดอื
ซึ่งแตกต่างจากคนไทยคนไทยเราใช้กล้วยน้ำ
ว้าอืแล้วก็ไม่ใช้กล้วยที่นิ่มๆสุกคกล้วย
นิ่มๆเอามาทอดเป็นกล้วยทอดไม่อร่อยต้อง
เป็นกล้วยห่ามก็คือกำลังจะสุก
อืมมันจะมีกล้วยสีเขียวดิบๆกินแล้วมียาง
หนึบๆโอันนี้ไม่ได้อืไม่อร่อยต้องเป็น
กล้วยที่ระหว่างดิบกับสุกอยู่ตรงกลางเรา
เรียกว่ากล้วยหามนะอืนะกล้วยห่ามเนี่ยเอา
ไปทอดอร่อยอือแล้วก็มาผ่าเป็น 2 ซีกอืไม่
ได้ทอดเป็นทั้งลูกนะเอามาผ่าครึ่งแล้วก็
ไปชุบแป้งอือเแบบคนไทยใช่มั้ยูชิใช่ค่ะที
เนี้ของคนไทยอ่ะถ้าเราถ้าเราเออคิดอ่ะ
กล้วยของเราเนี่ยก็ไม่เหมือนกล้วยของมาลู
จริงๆเดิมทีเดียวกล้วยแขกเนี่ยก็เป็น
เหมือนกับมีแป้งนะแล้วก็เอากล้วยมาชุบ
แป้งแล้วก็เอาไปทอดค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็นกล้วยทอด
ของคนไทยอ่ะมันถูกเปลี่ยนมาแล้วไงยังไงคะ
มันจะมีแป้งที่ทำมาจากแป้งข้าวเจ้าข้าว
ที่คนไทยกินน่ะนะอือฮึแล้วก็มีมะพร้าวขูด
ๆดๆเป็นเล็กๆเล็กๆ
แล้วก็มี
งาใส่น้ำตาลใส่
กระทิกล้วยแขกในแป้งที่ชุบทอดเี่มันจะมี
รสชาติหวานมันอร่อยบางคนใส่ถั่วด้วยอืมนะ
อก็น่ากินนะคะก็จะไม่เหมือนกล้วยของ
มุสลิมที่ขายในประเทศไทยอืมอนะมันมัน
เหมือนกับถูกพัฒนาเปลี่ยนไปตามรูปแบบของ
คนไทยที่ชอบอืมนะสมัย
ก่อนสมัยก่อนครูบีเวลาเรากินกล้วยแขกอ่ะ
เราต้องมีน้ำจิ้มหวานหวานค่ะเพราะว่า
กล้วยของคนมุสลิมจืดอออไม่ไม่ไม่หวาน
อย่างงี้หรอคะไม่มีรสชาติมันเป็นกล้วยไป
ชุบแป้งแล้วก็มาทอดมันก็เลยต้องถ้าคนไทย
กินคนไทยบอกว่ามันจืดๆเลี่ยนๆก็เลยต้องไป
จิ้มกับน้ำจิ้มที่มันมีถั่วใส่ถั่วแล้วก็
เป็นเอ่อน้ำตาลเหนียวๆมีน้ำส้มนิดหน่อย
เปรี้ยวๆผสมกันเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆแล้วก็มีถั่ว
มันๆแล้วก็จิ้มอืจิ้ม
กิ่นตอนหลังคนไทยบอกโอ๊ยมีกล้วยไปเอา
กล้วยของแขกมาเวลากินต้องมาทำน้ำจิ้มกิน
เนี่ยก็เลยทำแป้งที่มันมีรสชาติ
อร่อยอยู่แล้วไงใส่่มะพร้าวลงไปใส่น้ำตาล
ใส่กะทิใส่ถั่วหรือใส่งาอือืนะอันนี้ก็
คือพอเรากินเนี่ยก็คือมีรสชาติหวานมันถูก
มั้ยคะถูกต้องอร่อยไปเลยอืมนะไม่ต้องไม่
ต้องไปจิ้มน้ำจิ้มหวานๆไม่ต้องไม่ต้องค่ะ
เพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนเลยใช่เมื่อก่อนน่ะคน
ไทยอ่ะเราก็ไม่มีอาหารที่เป็นประเภทแบบ
ทอดอืมนะเรามีต้มมีนึ่งอืมีปิ้งปิ้งแบบ
หมูปิ้งอ่ะค่ะคือเอาไปเอาไปโดนไฟแป๊บๆ
แล้วก็เสร็จแล้วก็เอาไปย่างแบบไก่ย่าง
ต้องใช้เวลานานอืเราเรียกว่า
ย่างอาหารของคนไทยก็จะมีต้มผัดอืปิ้ง
ย่างทอดกับอบเนี่ยยังไม่มีเมื่อก่อนอใช่
มยใช่นะอันนี้ก็เลยกลายเป็นว่ากล้วยทอด
ที่คนไทยเอามาทำเนี่ยก็คือทำให้อร่อยในรส
ชาติที่คนไทยชอบใช่มั้ยอ่าใช่ค่ะไม่ต้อง
มีน้ำจิ้มมาจิ้มอ๋อแปลว่ากล้วยแต่ละที่
เนี่ยอ่าอย่างอะไรนะกล้วยแขกแล้วกล้วยแขก
ตอนเด็กๆครูชิกินน่ะมันมีรสชาติหวานมั้ย
อ่ะไม่หวานคจืดๆแล้วแล้วคุณย่าก็ชอบเอาไป
จิ้มน้ำจิ้มมมันคล้ายๆน้ำจิ้มไก่อ่ะครูบี
อเป็นน้ำจิ้มแล้วก็ใส่ถั่วเหมือนเหมน้ำ
จิ้มที่เราจิ้มทอดมันน่ะอืใช่มยมีมีปลา
ที่เขาเอาไปทอดแล้วก็เวลากินเนี่ยมันต้อง
มาจิ้มไม่มีรสชาติเปรี้ยวๆหวานๆ
อือเป็นเป็นเป็นเหมือนน้ำจิ้มอย่างงั้น
เลยเหรอคะใช่ค่ะสมัยก่อนมีกล้วยแขกที่
ต้องจิ้มน้ำจิ้มค่ะคูณบีเวลากินต้องจิ้ม
น้ำจิ้มกินโหก็คนไทยบอกว่าต้องมาจิ้มน้ำ
จิ้มก็น่าจะทำกล้วยที่มันกินแล้วอร่อยเลย
ดี
กว่า
ใช่ทอดเสร็จแล้วก็หยิบเข้าปากแล้วก็กิน
ได้เลยค่ะครูชิอืมทีเนี้ยอาหารของคน
อินเดียอ่ะอาหารของคนมาเลเซียมาลายูจะมี
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับทอดอืเข้ามาเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยอาหารที่เป็นเรื่องของการทอดที่ใช้
น้ำมันเยอะๆน้ำมันท่วมๆแบบเนี้ยก็เริ่ม
เข้ามาในประเทศไทยเหมือนกันทางตอนใต้ของ
ประเทศไทยก่อนนะอือฮึค่ะนะแล้วก็เหมือน
กับแพร่หลายไปอ่ะค่ะเริ่มรู้จักเริ่มมีคน
รู้จักเริ่มมีคนขายแล้วก็เริ่มมีคนกินอื
นะคะอ่าใช่ถ้าเราไปเช็คว่าอาหารของกลุ่ม
ไหนเนี่ยมาก่อนนะก็จะเป็นอาหารของคน
มาลายูอ่ะมาก่อนอืแล้วมันแพร่กระจายไปที่
อินเดียด้วยอืนะคเป็นเรื่องของอะไรอ่ะการ
การการทอดอืมอาหารที่มาจากการทอดใช่มั้ย
ใช้น้ำมัน่แต่ถ้ามันฝรั่งทอดเฟรนช์ฟราย
เนี่ยอันนี้เรารู้แล้วมาจากยุโรป
อเมริกาทีเนี้ยเค้าบอกว่าแล้วที่มาของ
กล้วยทอดเนี่ยอาจจะมาเพราะว่าทางตอนใต้
เขาจะมีการทอดขนมชนิดนึงนะคะเราเรียกว่า
ขนุนจำปาดะค่ะครูบีเนี่ยเป็นขนุนแบบเนี้ย
มันจะนิ่ม
ๆอืเนื้อมันจะนิ่มๆเวลากินเนี่ยมันจะลื่น
บึ๊ดลื่นบึดลงคอเนี่ยกินแบบเนี้ยไม่อร่อย
ค่ะเค้าจะเอาไปทอดอืมเป็นขนุนเหรอคะูชิ
ใช่ค่ะขนุนทางภาคใต้ของประเทศไทยมาจาก
มาลูเนี่ยแหละค่ะมันเป็นการลอกเปลือกมา
แล้วก็จะเป็นเอ่อขนุนแต่ละแต่ละเม็ดแต่ละ
เม็ดเนี่ยเราเรียกแต่ละยวงนะแต่ละยวงแต่
ละยวงแต่ละยวงเนี่ยนะคะมันกินแล้วมันแบบ
มันอาจจะติดคอแล้วลื่นลงไปไงเขาก็เลยเอา
อันเนี้ยค่ะไปชุบแป้งทอดอนะคะเป็นเป็น
จำปาดะอ่ะอเป็นแบบเหมือนกับเอ่อแป้งทอด
แบบนั้นนะคะก็เลยเข้าใจว่าแต่พอมามาภาค
กลาง
ไงพอมาถึงภาคกลางคุบีค่ะเป็นยังไงคะภาค
กลางขนุนภาคกลางเนื้อจะแข็งไม่นิ่มเหมือน
กับอๆเอ่อขนุนของภาคใต้อืเนื้อขนุนของภาค
กลางมันจะแข็งๆเอามาชุบแป้งแล้วก็มาทอด
มันไม่อร่อยมันไม่เข้ากันอืนะลองทดลองทอด
แล้วมากินเนี่ยไม่อร่อยเหมือนเอ่อเข้าทอด
จำปาดะอุ๊ยถ้าฤดูขนุนของภาคใต้จำปาดะ
เนี่ยเป็นอาหารที่แบบคนรอซื้อเลยค่ะ
โอ้โหแปลว่าเป็นอาหารที่อร่อยนะทางภาคใต้
ประเทศไทยเหรอคะครูชิใช่ค่ะครูบีข้างนอก
มันเป็นแป้งกรอบๆพอถัดไปมันเป็นเนื้อขนุน
ที่หวานๆนิ่มๆอืพอถัดเข้าไปเป็นเมล็ดที่
มันแข็งๆมันๆมันได้หลายหลายอารมณ์ของการ
กินน่ะอืมนะเพราะว่าอย่างขนนเนี่ยมันมีรส
ชาติหวานด้วยไงูชิใช่ถูกมั้ยคะอ่ะถ้า
เดี๋ยวต้องต้องให้นักเรียนดูขนนชัดๆก่อน
เนาะเนี่ยอือหือแต่แต่ว่าทางภาคใต้เนี่ย
มันจะค่อนข้างแบบนิ่มกว่าใช่มั้ยใช่เนี่ย
เนื้อขนุนเนี่ยคือมันมีความความหวานอยู่
แล้วอืแล้วพอเค้าเอาไปทอดใช่มั้ย
คะพอเอาไปทอดเนี่ยมันก็จะแบบโอเห็นแล้ว
หิวอ่ะครู
ชิครูบีหิวค่ะตอนนี้
เออพอเห็นแล้วรู้สึกหิวนะคะอื
ออใชู่บีคือมันทอดทั้งเม็ดเลยไงออไอ้เม็ด
ข้างในที่มันแข็งๆอ่ะกินแล้วมันจะมันๆอื
แป้งข้างนอกกรอบๆผัดเข้าไปเป็นเนื้อขนุน
หวานๆนิ่มๆอเข้าไปอีกเป็นแข็งๆมันๆมันกิน
แล้วมันได้หลายรสชาติจำปาดะทอดนี่จะเป็น
อะไรที่แบบโอ้โหต้องรอให้มีฤดูจำปาดะฤดู
ดูขนุนที่จำปาดะออกอ๋อเพราะว่าโอยทอดขาย
ไม่ทันน่ะคนต่อคิวอ่ะูชิเพราะว่าอย่าง KFC
เนี่ยไก่ KFC เนี่ยราคาค่อนข้างแพงเนาะใน
ประเทศไทยมีอยู่ทุกห้างสรรพสินค้าบิ๊กซี
โลตัสเซ็นทรัลใช่มั้ยจะมี KFC นะมีร้าน
KFC แล้วก็ไก่ทอดน่ะคนไทยชอบกินใช่มั้
แต่ภาคใต้เนี่ยไม่ได้มีให้กินตลอด KFC
คือมีให้กินทุกวันใช่มยถ้าคุณมีเงินซื้อ
แต่ขนุนเนี่ยมันต้องรอไงครูชิอย่างที่ครู
ชิบอกต้นขนนเนี่ยเดี๋ยวให้ให้ดูเมันไม่
ได้มีลูกทุกฤดูเนาะใช่มันไม่ได้ออกทั้งปี
ค่ะูบีเนี่ยค่ะลูกขนุนนะคะแล้วก็มีต้น
เนี่ยบางปีมีขนุนบางปีมีนิดหน่อยเห็นมั้ย
คะโอ้โหเข้าใจเลยว่าจำปาดะใช่มั้ยคะใช่
ที่เขาเรียกเพอเป็นจำปาดะอ่ะเขาไม่นิยม
กินเนื้อเพราะเนื้อมันนิ่มมากคุณบีมัน
นิ่มแล้วก็หวานมากมีรสชาติหวานมากแล้วก็
นิ่มนิ่มจนเวลาเรากินเนี่ยมันจะลื่นรึดลง
ไปอ่ะ
อืนี่ไงูชิพอดูขนนของทางภาคใต้เนี่ยเนื้อ
มันนิ่มจริงเห็นมั้ยคะ
จับไปแล้วนะมันจะแป๊ดเลยอ่ะนิ่มมากเนี่ย
นะเนื้อแบบน่าจะนิ่มจนเละอ่ะกูชิใช่ถูก
ต้องแบบนั้นเลยครูบีคือแบบเละเหมือนแบบ
เหลวๆเลยนะเนี่ยใช่อ๋อก็เลยไม่นิยมกินแบบ
นี้นิยมเอามาทอดนะคะกรอบๆอืคือมันเคี้ยว
ไม่ได้ไงมันเคี้ยวไม่ได้เพราะเวลาเรากัด
ลงไปมันรึดมันลงไปเลยอ่ะมันไหลลงไปเลยครู
บีมันเคี้ยวไม่ได้เลยอ่ะเดี๋ยวติดคอลื่น
อืจะรู้สึกอึโอ้โหคำบ่อเราลงไปแล้วเรียบ
ร้อยค่ะเออนะอ๋ออันนี้ก็เลยกลายเป็นแบบ
จำปาดะชอดซึ่งเป็นขนุนมาจากขนุนอืใช่ที
เนี้ยคนมุสลิมอ่ะคนอิสลามใช่มั้ยมา
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมาอยู่กรุงเทพแล้วเนี่ยจะ
เอาขนุนภาคกลางอืภาคกลางของประเทศไทย
เนี่ยไปทอดขนุนภาคกลางมันเนื้อมันแข็งอื
เรานิยมกินขนุนเปล่าๆหรืออาจจะกินขนุนเอา
เอาขนุนมาหั่นแล้วไปใส่เอ่อขนมน้ำแข็ง
อะไรแบบนี้อค่ะเราก็จะไม่นิยมเอาไปทอด
เพราะไปทอดแล้วมันไม่อร่อยมันจืด
อืแล้วเม็ดมันก็จะแข็งเกินไปมันจะไม่
เหมือนกับขนุนทางภาคใต้อือืเค้าก็ไปมาคิด
ว่าอ้าแล้วเอาอะไรทอดล่ะเอามันมาทอดโอเค
มันทอดโอเคผ่านเอากล้วยมาทอดอุยดีมาก
อร่อยอื้อแน่นอนคเกิดคนมุสลิมพอมาอยู่ภาค
กลางเนี่ยไม่มีขนุนมาทอดก็เลยใช้กล้วยมา
ทอดขายค่ะเพราะว่ากล้วยเนี่ยมีตลอดทั้งปี
อืมหาซื้อได้ง่ายเนาะไปตลาดไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตก็ได้ก็มีกล้วยขายนะอ่า
หรือตลาดแบบคนไทยเนี่ยก็ราคาขาจะถูกแล้ว
ก็เอามาทอดขาย
ออแล้วอาหารมุสลิมอ่ะเราก็จะมักจะเรียก
ก๋ยเตี๋ยวของมุสลิมก็เรียกก๋วยเตี๋ยวแขก
ข้าวของมุสลิมเราก็เรียกข้าวแขกอ่ะสลัด
ของมุสลิมเราก็เรียกสลัดแขกอืมหน้าตามัน
ไม่เหมือนอืคือหน้าตามันไม่เหมือนกับสลัด
ของคนไทยก็เลยเรียกว่าสลัดแขกแขกที่แปล
ว่าแปลกไม่เหมือนอืก๋วยเตี๋ยวแขกก็คือ
หน้าตาไม่เหมือนก๋วยเตี๋ยวภาคกลางไงอืม
ไม่ไม่ไม่เหมือนก๋วยเตี๋ยวทั่วๆไปที่เรา
กินหรือเราเห็นนะคะอ่าเอ่อๆแล้วกล้วยรอคะ
กล้วยก็เลยเรียกว่ากล้วยแขกอือะไรที่คน
มุสลิมทำก็เลยแมีท้ายด้วยนะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยคาดเดาว่าคำว่าแขกจากคำว่ากล้วยแขก
เนี่ยมาจากกลุ่มแขกมาลูหรือกลุ่มแขก
มุสลิมที่มาอยู่ภาคกลางอ่ะแล้วก็มาใช้
ชีวิตอยู่ในภาคกลางทำมาหากินก็ทำอาหารที่
มาจากมันก็จะมีอาหารที่คนมุสลิมทานใช่
มั้ยมะตะบะอะไรค่ะโรตีมีอะไรแบบเนี้ยมัน
ก็จะเลยแบบมีลงท้ายคำว่าแขกต่อท้ายกล้วย
ของคนมุสลิมก็เลยเรียกว่ากล้วยแขกเหมือน
กันนั่นคือสิ่งที่เราค
กล้วยแขกมายังไงอืมนะจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยกล้วย
แขกกับกล้วยทอดเนี่ยเหมือนกันนะคะอ่าคน
ไทยกรุงเทพฯก็เรียกกล้วยทอดใช่มั้ยแต่พอ
เป็นมุสลิมที่เป็นคนเอากล้วยมาทอดเราเลย
เรียกกล้วยแขกอย่างเงี้เหรอครูชิอือหือ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ไม่ใช่แค่แค่ประเทศไทยใช่
มั้ยก็ยังมีอาหารของประเทศใกล้เคียงของ
เราอ่ะที่มีลักษณะคล้ายๆกล้วยกล้วยทอด
หรือกล้วยแขกเอ่อของคนไทยอ่ะนะค่ะเราก็
บอกว่าอาหารชนชาติในเอเชียที่ใกล้ๆกันก็
น่าจะเหมือนกันนี่
อืคล้ายกันเลยนะอ่าใช่ดูดิมันเหมือนกับแบ
มีการชุบแป้งแล้วเอาไปทอดนะอืนะนะอย่าง
อันแรกนี่ก็ชื่ออะไรเนี่ยปีชังโกเร็งออ่า
ภาษานี้น่าจะเป็นภาษาจากประเทศอะไรคะ
เนี่ยปีชาโกเร็งเนี่ยก็เป็น
เอ่อเป็นอาหารของมามาเลเซียมาลายูอืนะ
หรืออินโดนีเซียเมีมีโกเร็งกันนะคะมีปีซา
โกเร็งนะคะก็เป็นเพราะว่าโกเรงแปลว่าทอด
อืมนะก็คล้ายกันเนาะแล้วก็อันที่ 2 เี่
เป็น
จ้วยเจี้ยนอันนี้น่าจะเวียดนามมั้ยูชิใช่
ค่ะเป็นของเวียดนามอืนะบางทีเราก็เรียก
เป็นของญวนนะอืมเราเรียกเวียดนามบ้าง
เรียกญวนบ้างแล้วก็เจียนนะเจียน
เจียงนี่ก็เป็นของกัมพูชาอืนะก็คือ
เห็นมั้ยคล้ายๆกันก็คือเอากล้วยไปทอดนะอื
อือันนี้เป็นลักษณะก็หน้าตาคล้ายๆกล้วย
แขกบ้านเราอ่ะนะใช่นี่แหละก็เลยกลายเป็น
ว่ากล้วยแขกนะบางคนบางร้านเนี่ยเขียนนะ
กล้วยทอดแต่คนไทยก็ยังบอกว่ากล้วย
แขกเพราะว่าติดปากไงเคยเรียกกล้วยแขก
กล้วยแขกนะคะใช่นะคะก็อันนี้เนี่ยเราก็
คุยว่าอันนี้เชื่อเป็นชื่อแบบเป็นชื่อ
เป็นชื่อต่างชาติอืมีในประเทศไทยเท่านั้น
เพราะว่ากล้วยทอดหรือกล้วยแขกประเทศไทย
เนี่ยจะหน้าตาและรสชาติไม่เหมือนที่อื่น
เพราะเราใส่ทั้งมะพร้าวใส่ถั่วใส่งาใส่
น้ำตาลใส่มีรสชาติไม่จืดไม่ใช่ชุบแป้ง
เปล่าๆนี่ไงหวานมันหน้าตาเป็นอย่างงี้เลย
ค่ะนะกล้วยทอดหรือว่ากล้วยแขกเหมมี 2
ชื่อเลยนะคะเนี่ยูชิ
อ่าอร่อยค่ะนะเดี๋ยวต้องต้องไปกินแล้วล่ะ
พูดอย่างงี้นะคะหิวอ่าเพราะว่าแถวๆตลาด
ข้างหน้าปากซอยเนี่ยมีขายนะมีกล้วยแขก
แล้วก็มีกล้วยทอดอ่าข้างหน้าโลตัสก็มีค่ะ
อืป่ะครูบีเริ่มจะหิวแล้วแน่ๆใช่ค่ะอยาก
กินกล้วยแพรีบอกป่ะๆจะไปกิน
กล้วยโอเคแล้วเอาไว้เราจะมาคุยอาหารอื่นๆ
ค่ะที่มีชื่อต่างประเทศแต่มีแค่ประเทศไทย
ค่ะที่อื่นไม่มีอืเหมือนกล้วยแขกนะคะชื่อ
กล้วยแขกแต่มีที่ประเทศไทยนะคะงั้นวันนี้
ก็ลาทุกคนไปก่อนแล้วก็ขอบคุณูชิมากๆค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูบี